blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to
blinkist.com pakman all right welcome to
the show it's going to be a big big
vaccine show today why because the
approval of the pfizer vaccine by the
fda happened we said yesterday it was
expected to happen yesterday it happened
within hours of us uh recording the show
publishing the show and uh important to
remember this is this is pfizer moderna
is a few weeks behind but a very very
important development for a number of
different reasons the new york times
reporting the fda grants full approval
to the pfizer bio end tech covid19
vaccine the fda granted full approval
for the pfizer vaccine for people 16 and
older making it the first to move beyond
emergency use status in the united
states as we talked about yesterday
about a third of those refusing the
vaccine said
if and when there is full approval
they will go and get the vaccine and so
now it's time to figure out whether they
really will we are going to talk about
the vaccine requirements that are coming
down as a result and the new york times
also pointing out the decision is sure
to set off a cascade of vaccine
requirements by hospitals colleges
corporations and others the pentagon
responded immediately
saying all active duty service members
will be required to be vaccinated
oregon has adopted a vaccine requirement
for state workers
in a brief speech monday president biden
said he hoped the approval would prompt
many of the roughly 85 million americans
who are unvaccinated and eligible for
shots to get them so what are the
important things to remember
i already mentioned this is the pfizer
approval many people have gotten moderna
moderna is not yet fully approved still
approved under emergency use
moderna a few weeks behind in the
pipeline they filed for full approval
shortly after pfizer did and it would be
expected that within a few weeks that
vaccine would be approved as well again
important to remember that what the fda
has approved here is the two dose
regimen which is the standard emergency
use regimen for both the pfizer and the
modern vaccine there are people writing
to me and i briefly addressed this
yesterday well so they've approved the
two shot regimen but they're already
talking about a third dose at the eight
month mark immunocompromised folks have
already started getting a third dose
there's israeli data about the efficacy
of a third dose that's not currently
approved
fully and the expectation is that pfizer
will immediately ask for that third
booster shot at the eight month mark to
be approved as well
for now the world health organization is
leaning towards stick with two
let's use those would-be third doses and
get them to countries and to people that
haven't even had a single dose yet
that's going to help us get out of the
pandemic more quickly it's not a crazy
thing to suggest but in the united
states
there is going to be the availability i
got my flu shot at cvs the other day
and the pharmacist said we have the
supply
uh
they do moderna at least that cvs did
and they said once you're at eight
months you can just come get a third
dose we're not going to be um
restricting it to certain groups or
whatever the case may be so now we'll
start really there's now we're branching
we had one branch was which was waiting
for full approval we now have that
that's been met we now have two new
branches to look at one do the people
who said i'll get it once it's fully
approved do they stick to what they said
my prediction is some do and some move
the goal posts we already saw some of
the goalposts moving yesterday it was
exactly as i predicted was the approval
too quick was the approval politicized
was the approval rushed the question
being asked on fox news
a guest on steve bannon's program saying
this isn't even really an approval
we'll get to all of that later that's
number one and then number two
we are we were expecting and we're
already seeing and we'll talk about it
later on in the program a whole bunch of
new
organizations putting in place
vaccination requirements we're seeing
more schools and colleges we're seeing
more cities say even just to go to
restaurants and i'm curious to see will
there be hotel chains that say this is a
vaccinated only hotel
that sounds pretty good to me i would
lean towards going to that hotel chain
if i needed to go to a hotel and there
was a chain that did that is there an
airline that's willing to be the first
to say
you're going to need a vaccine to fly
with us after a certain date i would be
very interested in trying to fly
that airline and it should not come as a
shock that there are
millions of people
who will say i would never do that i
will quit my job if they say or i will
never fly that airline or whatever i
think for some of them that will apply
um but for many others as soon as it
becomes inconvenient to be unvaccinated
they're going to go and they're going to
get themselves vaccinated because people
value convenience significantly and
we're going to talk about that a little
bit later but next i do want to talk
about the pentagon
mandating vaccination for all 1.3
million active duty service members
so we expected that because they said it
that as soon as any of the covet 19
vaccines got full approval from the fda
the pentagon would say every military
service member has to go and get
vaccinated uh that is indeed happening
and the pentagon is mandating the
covid19 vaccine for the military the
hill reporting the u.s military will
move to mandate the vaccine for all
service members now that the pfizer
vaccine has full approval from the fda
the pentagon's top spokesperson
announced monday defense secretary lloyd
austin is quote prepared to issue
updated guidance requiring all service
members to be vaccinated these efforts
ensure the safety of our service members
and promote the readiness of our force
not to mention the health and safety of
the communities around the country in
which we live a timeline for when
service members must receive the shot
will be provided in the coming days the
defense department is preparing guidance
to the force to make the vaccine
mandatory with a timeline to be provided
in the coming days kirby would not
comment on any plans to do the same for
the moderna and jnj vaccine saying the
focus right now is moving forward to
implement a mandatory vaccination
regimen for pfizer i don't want to get
ahead of decisions that haven't been
made yet this is interesting in a number
of different ways
will there be service members that try
to quit now why do i say try to quit
it's not always that easy to just quit
the military and without going into all
the details depending on
what your service status is
you may be signed on for a contract of a
certain duration and you can still get
out of it but there are certain
requirements you either need to become
physically unfit or determined to be
incompatible with the mission or in some
way so it's not even that easy to just
say i quit
now the other
this isn't something to be happy about
the other reality is that there are many
people that are in the military because
they got sucked in by recruiters in the
first place we know that military
recruiters target lower income areas
where
people may
accurately or inaccurately assess their
opportunities
in the world as not so good
and recruiters are very good at framing
a career in the military as the best
option as a great option
and uh the best shot one might have
at making a good living and so there may
be lots of folks who don't want to get
vaccinated now
but correctly or incorrectly have
assessed that this is really the only
shot that they've got at making a good
living are they really going to quit now
or try to quit it seems very very
unlikely and at the end of the day i
want to restate that the military
already requires a bunch of vaccines
this is just adding one more
now with the full fda approval of the
pfizer vaccine there's really no
difference between this vaccine and
others that members of the military get
when they join up you got a bunch of
vaccines when you first signed up now
they've added another that's fully
approved and there's really no reason to
say no it's just the military this is
the way it works basically every
military in the world has policies like
this now let me address something very
specific about the military and vaccines
because two people wrote to me about
this i think there's an interesting
sort of anecdote to think about
there are some people saying
this is terrible
and it's just like when during the first
gulf war in the early 90s troops were
given the anthrax vaccine and it gave
many of them what's called gulf war
syndrome
gulf war syndrome is a cluster of
symptoms that includes fatigue headaches
joint pain insomnia dizziness memory
problems and some others and the claim
that some make is troops were given
an experimental anthrax vaccine
and it gave them gulf war syndrome
the first
important thing to mention is
it's not actually clear that the anthrax
vaccine gave anybody gulf war syndrome
there is an unexplained cluster of
symptoms that many gulf war service
members suffered
uh it has been speculated about that
maybe it was the anthrax vaccine but it
is not proven that's number one
number two
the status of the anthrax vaccine in the
early 90s and the covet vaccine today
the pfizer coveted vaccine today is
completely different
um the anthrax vaccine
was not even authorized for emergency
use in the early 90s it really was
experimental in the real sense of the
word it was used off label there was no
presidential order and it was not even
authorized by emergency use never mind
full fda approval we have today is it's
not even emergency use now based on
yesterday's approval we have a fully
approved vaccine period
um and it is not an analogous situation
whatsoever now imagine being willing
to fight and die for the country
but not to get the vaccine
that will better enable you to do that
and i think there's going to be a ton of
i'm not getting that damn vaccine
followed by actually you are
yes sir i'm going to get that vaccine
thank you very much there's going to be
a ton of that some people may quit some
people may try to quit but ultimately uh
this is just another vaccine on the long
list that's required by the military now
after the break we're going to talk
about
outside of the military the very long
list of mandates and requirements of the
vaccine now that it has been fully
approved let me know your thoughts on
this is is something going on in your
community an organization your employer
your school whatever that now says now
that it's fully approved you've got to
get it you can let me know on twitter
where you can find me at deepakman
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
remember that the david pakman show is
made possible primarily by folks like
you who grab a membership we do an extra
show every day just for our paid members
and you can sign up in uh
i don't know 30 45 seconds with average
computer proficiency at
joinpacman.com and you can take
advantage of the discount
uh code that we are making available
21 it'll apply to the membership of your
choice at joinpacman.com
all right let's go through the list the
rapidly growing it's almost impossible
to keep up with the growing list of
vaccine requirements and mandates now
coming forward
from
educational institutions
employers
states with regard to state workers all
happening very quickly in the aftermath
of the pfizer covid vaccine
receiving full fda approval something
sort of a watershed moment that was
weighted uh awaited by many on both the
pro and anti-vaccine sides the
anti-vaccines either hoping it wouldn't
happen or saying
if it happens then i will get vaccinated
let's see if they do and of course those
of us on the pro-vaccine side uh waiting
for what was obviously going to happen
with the hope that it will help get us
out of the pandemic now we've already
talked about the pentagon announcing all
1.3 million
u.s service members will be required to
be vaccinated we don't know the exact
timeline yet presumably it will be a
couple of months but the military will
be vaccinating all active duty service
members we've previously also talked
about new york city bill de blasio the
mayor in new york city
enacting mandates for indoor dining and
a ton of other leisure and entertainment
activities in the state of new york over
the weekend in the city of new york
rather over the weekend there was a very
very extreme anti-vaccine a protest
maybe we'll look at some clips of that
tomorrow it's a little difficult to
watch quite frankly the cringe is high
and the delusions are even higher
but let's look at some of the other
requirements that are now being put in
place and speaking of new york the new
york city public schools organization
has issued a full coveted vaccine
mandate for all staff you want to work
at new york city schools public schools
you want to teach at new york city
public schools you will have to be
vaccinated that'll take effect september
27th
and
all education employees will be required
to upload proof of at least the first
dose
to an online portal
going from uh new york to texas texas
instruments a for-profit company in
texas will require all u.s based
employees to get the covid19 vaccine
they are based in dallas it is a
it's really a semiconductor company
although i know texas instruments for
those graphing calculators that were
so much fun in high school math they
will be required both employees and
contractors will be required to be
vaccinated by october 29th otherwise
they will lose their jobs
disney has reached a deal with the
service trades council union to require
all of its unionized employees
working at walt disney world in florida
to be fully vaccinated by october 22nd
of 2021 fully vaccinated presumably
meaning both doses meaning at the latest
they will have to get that first dose uh
in that's in the second half of
september uh remember that last month
disney mandated all of its salary and
non-union hourly employees get
vaccinated by the end of september and
now a deal for all of the union
employees to be vaccinated as well
anecdotally in seattle there are now
more than 130 different bars and
restaurants requiring vaccine proof
and that list is growing relatively
quickly expected to be even faster now
with full vaccine approval
and then we also have a bunch of
different stories out of new jersey new
jersey is going to require covet
vaccination for teachers and for state
workers the governor there is phil
murphy a democrat he announced the
mandate
during a news conference i believe
yesterday
pre-k through 12th grade teachers and
staff and state employees
must be fully vaccinated by october 18th
or they will have to get tested once or
twice a week
now
the testing or vaccine i'm not really
big on it
um but there are places that are doing
it it's sort of a softer vaccine
requirement to say if you're not you
will have to be tested once or twice a
week and then for something completely
different coming just showing the the
breadth of places we are seeing these
requirements navajo nation
has now issued a vaccine mandate for uh
tribal workers
this is happening the question now is
what are the resistors going to do
some of them are just going to go and
get vaccinated without question but are
there some folks that will actually quit
a job over a vaccine requirement
are they more likely to fake their
vaccination results will they are we
going to see lawsuits come forward
saying that this is a violation of
who knows what but just some kind of
legal attempt to resist this is going to
become a huge issue now the easiest
thing from the standpoint of just like
do i go and find a fake vaccine card do
i hire a lawyer and file a lawsuit or
whatever the case may be the easiest
thing continues to be
just go and get vaccinated it's even
easier to actually get vaccinated than
to fake a vaccine card it's legal as
opposed to faking a vaccine card and it
provides you with some protection
particularly against serious
hospitalization or death so it's much
more useful than a fake vaccine card
one more thought on this former guest on
the show radley balco it's been years
but radley was a guest on the program i
think more than a decade ago he had a
funny but relevant tweet
where he said here's an idea
set aside 15 million pfizer vaccines
give them a weird new name
like hydroxy iversink
send them to doctors and veterinarians
and acupuncturists
and run a viral marketing campaign
calling hydroxy ivor zinc the secret
covered cure the government doesn't want
you to know about
that might actually work it's the type
of thing that might actually work um and
quite frankly if you want to have these
people go and get vaccinated
start claiming joe biden's going to ban
the vaccine i these people will go and
get vaccinated the next day if they
believe joe biden is going to ban it
because if joe biden supports something
it must be bad
and if joe biden wants to ban something
it must be good i would actually look
into that uh the ethics of it i don't
know but it certainly would be effective
all right we predicted yesterday and it
was so obvious this is as i say many
times this is not like a pat on the back
that this was some amazing prediction uh
it was obvious that now that the pfizer
coveted vaccine is fda approved
you were going to start hearing from the
right saying i don't know that we can
trust this approval
this may have been rushed
the biden administration may have
accelerated it when it really shouldn't
have been approved yet or whatever the
case may be
now why is this relevant this is
relevant again because i only you know i
know that the right is now just about
owning the libs
i don't care about crap like that okay
what i want is
let's get people vaccinated so the icus
can start emptying out and so that we
have room in hospitals for people who
get into a car accident get hurt at work
whatever the case may be that my
priority is health okay
one third of those who were resisting
the vaccine said
if and when there is a full approval
uh then i will go and get vaccinated so
that's a really important thing so we
care about how
um media and the right react to news of
the approval
here is a fox news segment that opens
yesterday by saying
was it rushed
was it rushed take a listen
a fox news alert for you now the fda
just giving full approval to pfizer's
coping vaccine it's the first vaccine to
get that full approval and in record
time too that has critics asking if the
process was rushed was it well let's
bring in admiral brett gerard former now
okay
there are people who said
it's unfair to show only that because dr
brett jarrar comes in and says no it's
safe i agree with you
but
it's still teasing it you're leading
with that and it's fox news and you know
the audience now dr brett gerard comes
in and he says it's safe but notice that
40 seconds later
the other anchor bill hemmer is going to
say by the way what took so long wait a
second was it rushed or did it take too
long which is it why can't you guys
decide health and human services
assistant secretary and of course he was
our testings are so tell us a little bit
sir about what this moment means to get
full approval sir
well this is a very big moment in uh
operation warp speed history in the
history of our vaccines our fight
against the pandemic prior to this we
had emergency use authorization what
that really meant is that the public
health benefits outweighed the known and
potential harms what this says today is
we know the benefits we know the harms
and this vaccine is safe and effective
and every confidence can be given to
that americans should feel very good
even better than they did yesterday
about getting the vaccine yeah what took
so long
oh man
you know the critics are worried this
was done too quickly it was was it done
too quickly no absolutely not oh what
took so long to get this approved come
on guys come on guys so let's listen to
a little bit more
well it is a complicated process and i
know there are many many good
professionals incredible professionals
at the fda i was acting commissioner
it does take a while because all the
data is looked at in detail you know
every page is turned the facilities are
inspected
however uh again as i've said before i
think it's unconscionable that the biden
administration does not have an fda
commissioner even nominated to provide
leadership it might have been a little
faster but it is complicated there's a
lot of material and americans should
feel very confident in the process some
have said that they were hesitant to get
the vaccine and point into this lack of
full approval and how do you think the
administration and its goal to try to
get more people vaccinated can utilize
this news
well i think the american people will
utilize the news the poll said about 30
percent of those who have not been
vaccinated right would become vaccinated
feel very confident about that once the
vaccine received full approval that just
happened the vaccine is fully approved
and i'm very hopeful that this will uh
push people uh over the edge to go get
the vaccine because it is okay so you
guys get the point so so listen um the
full video shows the guests saying uh it
wasn't rushed and people should get the
vaccine that's a very good thing that's
good the framing up front
and the fact that fox still seeds the
talking point was it rushed can we trust
it their first instinct is to lead the
segment with can we really even trust
this approval
which is already what many fox news
viewers are prone to believe can we
really trust this and so i get that just
the first 12 seconds were floating
around yesterday and there were people
saying it's dishonest to say
that the entire segment meant to tell
people that it was rushed you're right
you're right and there were some people
who only played the first 12 seconds
i've played the full two minutes okay
you're right bret gerard says it's safe
and it wasn't rush i played the rest and
i'm glad that that's what the guest said
but this is a channel whose audience
lives in 15 second sound bites many of
whom want to believe it was rushed and
many of whom will see that question
asked and the rest of the stuff doesn't
matter
and so this is really important bret
gerard cited the same study i've been
citing one-third of the vaccine
resistant have said resistant maybe is
not a good word because it means
something else of the vaccine hesitant
have said
if there's full approval i will go and
get vaccinated let's now see if they do
we'll have more coverage of the reaction
from right wing media to the full
approval later on in the show and also
on the david pakman show instagram which
you can find at david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
it's great to welcome to the program
today tom standage who is deputy editor
of the economist and also author of the
book a brief history of motion from the
wheel to the car to what comes next uh
tom it's great to have you on today
really appreciate it thanks very much
for having me you know i've uh i'm
actually reading right now the book
1491.
and uh one of the interesting anecdotes
in it is about how was it that so few
spaniards were able to defeat these
these large armies of uh of inca and
other groups in what is now central
america and one of the things that's
mentioned was the superior
understanding and use of the wheel in
all of its different forms by by the
spanish
and although i wasn't reading that
because i was going to be interviewing
you it i think the importance of the
wheel and ultimately of automobiles it
really cannot be overstated in terms of
its impact on human society and culture
can it well i think that's true but i
also think it's very easy to overlook um
so for example someone once said that if
you're a fish right you're swimming
around in water all the time but fish
have no concept of what water is because
they're just surrounded by it they just
assume that's you know that's the way
the world is um and i think we're sort
of the same with cars we we live in a
world that has been shaped by cars and
we can't imagine it really being any
other way so what i'm trying to do with
this book is sort of point out the water
to the fish and say how did we get here
and how might things look different and
if we are going to be less reliant on
cars in the future and i think we
probably are um then you know it's
helpful to see if we're going to start
unpicking cars from the fabric of our
civilization and from everyday life then
it's useful to see how it was woven in
so that's really what i'm what i'm
trying to do yeah in 1491 the other
factor we should mention of course was
disease i mean the fact that indeed the
europeans took all those contagious i'm
sure the wheel played a role the other
interesting thing is that american
cultures were aware of the wheel um but
generally didn't use it um it was uh it
was used in some toys uh and this is one
of the striking things you know the
wheel is a great cliche uh about the
wheel is it's well the greatest
invention it's in history and this sort
of thing um but the amazing thing is how
many cultures knew about it but didn't
use it another example would be the
egyptians who managed to build the
pyramids entirely without using wheels
uh they knew about wheels because the
mesopotamians next door had them but the
the egyptians just found it much easier
to move things around on rafts on the
nile and rollers and the fact there was
no wheeled vehicle on earth that could
have taken a a block that you would use
to build the pyramid it was just those
pyramid blocks are really really big and
heavy so um so this idea that wheels are
the greatest thing ever is a very recent
idea it's a sort of early 20th century
idea and it's at the point where we're
reshaping the world around wheeled
vehicles that we decide that actually
wheels are totally awesome but that's a
relatively recent way of looking at
things yeah i uh
i think sometimes it's missed by lots of
people
that in cities towns villages i mean in
much of what is when i say the developed
world i don't even mean the west but
just even parts of any country that is
what we would consider developed at all
the um amount of uh the planning and and
surface area
that is geared around prioritizing
wheeled vehicles over
walking and and that unless you think
about it it may not be apparent to many
people yeah well i mean it's it's more
of the it's obviously most most
recognizable in
in the us which has these laws about you
know if you build a new retail
development you have to have a certain
number of car parking spaces right by
one estimate there's six parking spaces
i think for every car in the u.s
um so i mean that's at about 30 percent
of the area of a typical u.s city is
parking um so i mean it's it's amazing
how much space is is um is given over to
vehicles and i think one of the
interesting stories um that i really you
know found uh i was struck by when i was
researching the book was the extent to
which um you know this this handing over
of so much space to the car is a very
recent thing it's only happened in the
past hundred years i mean even if you
look at photographs of streets from say
1910 in europe and the us um you don't
see parked cars along the side of the
street um and then and you also see if
you look at film from the early 20th
century uh there's a very famous film of
um uh going down san francisco um in
about i think it's you know first decade
in the 20th century it's just before the
big earthquake and um
and it's amazing that you've got all
these different kinds of vehicles and
people you know weaving in and out of
each other yeah um and then in the 1920s
you get this big change where they the
car drivers say well no this is slowing
us down everyone else needs to get out
of the way roads are for cars they're
definitely not for pedestrians they're
definitely not for horse draw vehicles
frankly we don't much like street cars
either because they get in the way um
and so the supremacy of the car really
becomes a thing at that point and you
know nowadays you know if you stand in
the middle of the road you're an idiot a
car's gonna hit you of course it is what
are you doing there um but that's not
the way streets used to work and again
this is something that we sort of take
for granted if we've grown up in a world
that's full of cars um but that's not
the way things were and it's you know
not the way things have to be and if you
go to some parts of the world it's not
like that and you do have much more of a
sort of you know sharing of street space
and similarly even some western
countries have decided to take back some
of that space from cars we've seen a lot
of this in the pandemic but it was
already happening in places like oslo
and helsinki where quite a lot of the
city center you know spaces car parking
was given given to bike lanes areas
pedestrianized and so on so i think
we're trying to sort of rediscover what
a less car-centric world would look like
yeah and i think one of the there's this
kind of uh i don't know if it's a it's
not really a thought experiment there's
this line that's often mentioned about
you know humans don't really know what
comes next and what the next advancement
would be because if you asked the horse
and buggy people right before cars came
to be what they wanted for better
transportation they would say a more
reliable or a faster horse and buggy
which which means they missed the
possible paradigm shift of cars
with that as a kind of framework
when we talk about electric vehicles
when we talk about self-driving
etc
do you think that we're even really
talking about what the next paradigm
shifts will be in wheel transportation
or or is it more likely about well i
think i think we're in danger of falling
into a historical trap so this book you
know it tells the story of wheeled
vehicles starting with the first wheels
and then looking at you know
various attempts to make steam-powered
vehicles and trains and bicycles and
then you get to cars and cars kind of
take over um and then i try to look at
what's coming next but i start the book
and the reason i think this this whole
history is worth looking at so much now
by comparing the current situation with
the situation in the 1890s and in the
1890s it was it was becoming apparent
that the dependency that big
fast-growing cities had on the horse and
horse-based transport was completely
unsustainable so the population of
horses in places like london and new
york was growing much faster than the
population of people and more and more
horses per person were needed to move
goods and people around and railways
made it worse because you have more
goods and people coming in and out of
cities
and so the more you have those long
distance links the more you need
capacity within the city to move people
and goods around and so this was
becoming you know recognized as a big
problem there was more and more horse
manure piling up in the streets it was a
big pollution problem it was a big
health problem there were lots and lots
of traffic jams it was very very noisy
um there were accidents and so on and so
on and so people were
they realized this was unsustainable but
they weren't sure what was going to come
next and then the the automobile is
invented at around this time it's you
know it's been in the works for actually
about you know
a century or longer depending on how you
look at it but um
the the proponents of the automobile say
it's going to solve these problems
you're not going to have horsemen you're
you're not going to have traffic because
taking away the the horse they're
originally called horseless carriages
will mean that these vehicles take up
less space on the street so they can
move faster
they're not going to make as much noise
because they've got rubber tyres so
streets are going to be much quieter and
there aren't going to be any accidents
because you haven't got horses to kind
of kick people or or run away and um of
course all of these predictions turn out
to be wrong and we get more traffic and
more noise and more accidents and the
pollution is not so visible but it's
still just as problematic in the form of
particulates and um and carbon dioxide
but what's interesting is that the
original way that this is portrayed is
as horseless carriages in other words
it's in a negative way so we take away
the horse and our problems go away and
now a century later we've a bit more
than a century we've recognized that um
that our car based
transport system is also unsustainable
for environmental reasons and again
there's this sort of you know apparently
simple fix which is fine we just make
everything electric or we make
everything driverless and then you know
we've kind of fixed it um and i think we
the risk is that we fall into the trap
of of like you know if we just change
that one thing everything else will stay
the same and the the story of the cast
shows you that that's not the case
because changing from horse drawn to uh
vehicles to cars
had all of these unexpected consequences
and i'm sure the same would be true if
we tried to just apply one of these
fixes so what i'm really arguing for in
this book what i think is going to
happen is that we're going to have less
of a monoculture in urban transport when
we had a monoculture based on
horse-drawn vehicles then we have in
many parts of the world a monoculture
based on on cars and i think what we're
moving towards in the future is much
more of a mixture of modes of transport
so not just buses and and public
transport but things like bike ride
rental
ride hailing scooters
cycle lanes more walking i mean just all
of these things and i call this the
internet of motion and the reason i
think this is kind of a much more
feasible alternative to to using cars
for everything than it used to be is
because of the smartphone and what the
smartphone allows you to do is knit
together all of these different
transport modes so you can say to your
phone i want to go from here to here and
it will say well there's a bus arriving
in two minutes at the end of the street
so take that and then get off and then
you know get onto
i don't know a scooter or or a ride hail
or something like that but you can
actually integrate all these forms of
transport in ways that you couldn't
before we had smartphones so in that
sense the successor to the car and car
based sort of transport culture is the
smartphone but it's because it allows
you to combine all these other things so
yeah i think the idea that we just kind
of haven't got to go on the way we are
now but with electric motors instead of
internal combustion engines i think is
is simplistic and i think it's wrong
one of the things that i'm curious to
get your thoughts on is that both when
it comes to automobile travel
and air travel it's sort of been a while
since there's been a real paradigm shift
in it getting significantly faster now i
don't think the most important thing is
speed and there's this obsession with
speed and efficiency but i think it's
it's an interesting topic which is
um when you consider
you know okay vehicles today may have a
higher top speed than they had 50 years
ago but due to congestion and due to so
many other things your effective
traveling speed in a vehicle is not
dramatically faster than when the
highways were first built that was a big
advancement highway speed as it was in
the 1990s it's eight miles an hour so it
hasn't changed at all
right
right
when it comes to air travel we had this
phase where you had the concorde
supersonic but it was
very expensive and inefficient and loud
and now united airlines has committed
again to supersonic but basically you
know planes have basically been going
550 miles an hour for a very long time
now and it seems out of sync with the
dramatic advancement in so many other
areas computer processing speed etc what
do you make of that um i think it's a
logistical thing so if you look at the
era when when concord was running so
concord could basically do um london to
jfk in
what something like three hours right
instead of instead of six or seven um
so but if you actually if if you're
somewhere in london so here i live in on
the other side of london to east london
um so it would take you so at best it
would take me an hour to get to heathrow
airport and i probably should allow two
and then obviously i have to check in
two hours before the flight
and i've got to go through security and
all that kind of stuff so basically i
have to leave four hours before the
plane takes off then when i get to jfk i
have to stand in line maybe for a couple
of hours to get through immigration um i
mean
right but it has been i mean it varies
you know even if you even if you're
flying at the front of the plane you get
off the plane there you you know if
another planes come in then there may be
a there may be a lot of cute you may
have to wait for your luggage then you
have to get into manhattan which is
again you find a cab and um i mean i
like i tend not to take a cab because it
makes me feel ill so i prefer to take
the air train in the subway but again
that takes you an hour to get to the you
know to the to the um to midtown um so
so again you're you're looking at
basically a whatever that is
12 15 hour process and concord takes
kind of four hours off the middle bit
but it's right that's not really
affecting the given how much more
expensive it is it's not really
affecting the overall
um
door-to-door travel time that much and
so the number of people who are prepared
to pay
you know that much more money to just
take a take three or four hours off the
middle of a 12-hour process was not big
enough to make it work and we'll see
what happens with this new generation of
supersonic planes but i mean you know
the i mean you can't fly supersonic over
land and so they're trying to come up
with various you know fixes for that but
um you know if there's one route in the
world it was going to work on it would
be um london jfk and that was the route
that you know concord was was most
effective on it just it didn't add up so
so yeah i think the thing to watch out
for here and i don't go into this in the
book because it's um it's you know not
about wheels and um but it's this idea
of sub-orbital transport and this is
something that uh elon musk has talked
about i mean people have talked about
this for ages but he's actually building
a vehicle now that um that may even fly
in the next few weeks that we might see
doing this um and this is where you
basically launch a rocket but instead of
going into orbit uh so to get it if you
go into orbit if the space station
orbits about once every 90 minutes so if
you get into the lowest possible earth
orbit um you're going around the world
once every 90 minutes and another way of
looking at that is if you launch
yourself into an orbit that doesn't
quite
um it doesn't quite make it into orbit
so it's just sub-orbital and then comes
down on the other side of the world
you'll get there you know in 45 minutes
to an hour so this is the idea that you
could fly from pretty much anywhere to
anywhere in less than an hour if you
took a sub-orbital trajectory and the
starship may be able to do that then
you've got this big problem again if you
have to build space ports outside cities
and musk is talking about floating space
ports and so so that's that's a
potential um you know game changer in
terms of uh uh of those things but i
think we're still going to come back to
you know i like to say even if we build
hyperspace tunnels from you know from
london to new york you're still going to
have to have security around them you're
still going to have limited capacity and
you're still going to have to go to the
hyperspace port which is probably on the
other side of town so then you then
you're london to jfk you know london to
new york you know maybe you can maybe
you can take a few hours out of it again
but you're still not getting it down to
zero and you can have that technology in
everyone's homes and you can like step
through your
your hyperspace port into your holiday
home in another country then uh you know
i can't see that that can't see that
working and we don't even know if this
is possible so so yeah i think it's a
very good point that actually these
boring logistical constraints actually
um end up being the most important
factor we've been
speaking with the book's author tom
standish who's deputy editor of the
economist tom really a pleasure speaking
with you today i appreciate it
thank you thanks for having me
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com david pakman show all right
let's get to a couple of other um
non-vaccine things that i wanted to go
over we're still dealing with
the aftermath in many different ways of
the january 6th trump riots and um there
is a really interesting exchange between
two members of congress that i want to
look at with you today one of them is a
member of congress you may not be
familiar with its democratic congressman
joseph morell
from new york the other guy is someone
you probably would be familiar with it's
republican congressman jim jordan who
was one of the
members of congress trying to stand in
the way of the certification of the 2020
presidential election on january 6th and
who
uh
there was an attempt made to put him on
the committee investigating the trump
riots when really he seems maybe more
like a witness or even a co-conspirator
in those events but regardless he had a
really interesting exchange yesterday
at a hearing
meant to be about
voter
laws gerrymandering access to voting etc
and he
utilized a uh rhetorical crutch
that a lot of these what i call
pseudo-insurrectionists
light insurrectionists have been using
when confronted with
we're now how many months out we're now
nine months out from the election
are you ready to say that joe biden
really won and they have this rhetorical
crutch they use where they say
i admit
joe biden is president
and of course that's a way to not really
answer the question so let's take a look
at it this is very interesting the gist
here is his talking point is not
actually an answer to the question okay
so let's jump right in if there's been
all this suppression that that that
previous democrats of the speakers have
talked about sure didn't work very well
because we have record turnout which is
as we've said now multiple times the
ranking member said it i think all the
repo
so what he's arguing here is we don't
really need to do anything about voter
suppression because it clearly doesn't
exist because we had record turnout in
the election this is his line of
reasoning and then joe morrell cuts in
it's a good thing so of course that
hasn't happened so disgrace i also find
it curiouser and curiouser
that
mr jordan you would use 2020 data on
election participation when you won't
even acknowledge the outcome of the same
election right i'm not i've been
knowledgeable
have you did joe biden win this election
there was no fraud you're prepared to
say that he's president united states no
that he's the president of the united
states and joe morrell points out you're
not answering my question jim that's not
what i asked you did he win the election
you said he's the president of the
united states that's only because we
were here while the capital was being
besieged by thousands of people
on overturning and stuck around to be
able to confirm the results of the
electoral college that's why you
acknowledge the president
all i've said is we should look into
concerns that lots of voters have i've
never said that he didn't win he's the
president united states but i said we
should look into the concerns i think
that's just common sense well looking at
concerns is fine i just the problem is
you guys don't have to i don't know how
many court cases
so this is this is important to
understand this is a tool that is used
really often it's a rhetorical tool
that's used in general which is you're
asked a question where
the real answer that's the substantive
answer would be politically
disadvantageous or it might be
disadvantageous to the point you're
trying to make
so you answer it but you're not really
answering it substantively you're
responding but you're not answering it
substantively there's a classic example
of this that i want to play for you guys
this is any opportunity i have to play
this i take because it's just such a
great example this is back in the bush
era
a former deputy assistant attorney
general john yu
was being asked by congressman john
conyers
is there anything a president couldn't
order done to a prisoner
bearing the prisoner alive
whatever and john you i i've actually
used this in the class i taught john u
answers every other question other than
the one being asked so let's look at
this together this is it's really worth
understanding this rhetorical crutch
because it's used so often here we go
is there anything mr professor you
that the president could not order to be
done to a suspect
if he believed it necessary for national
defense
well
mr chairman i think that goes back to
the quote you just read because
no i'm just asking you the question
maybe it does or doesn't but what do you
think i think it's the same question
that i was asked well what's the answer
first can i can i make clear i'm not
talking about and you don't have to make
anything clear just answer the question
council so this by the way this is all
the build up this is not actually using
that crutch but he will
i just want to make sure i'm not saying
anything you don't have to worry about
not saying just answer the question okay
my my thinking right now yes right now
okay my thinking right now this moment
yes this this moment mr chairman
is that uh
you know first
the question you're posing what is the
answer
mr i'm not trying to make you uh i get
it okay let me answer the ques i will
answer that no you you've wasted you're
wasting my time look council
we've all practiced law hold
could the president
order a suspect buried alive
mr chairman i don't think that i have
ever
i'm asking you to given the advice that
the president could bury something so so
remember
this is at the heart of
what can we do what what counts as
torture what's not this is this was a
major issue at the time if this was
before you were following politics this
was a issue of paramount importance
and the question was
if if the president said
bury this suspect alive
could they legally do that and john you
says i've never given a president that
advice that's that but that's not the
question somebody alive i didn't ask you
if you ever gave him advice i asked you
do you think the president could order a
suspect buried alive mr chairman my view
right now is that i don't think a
president would no american president
would ever have to order that or feel it
necessary
[Laughter]
that's again not actually answering the
question that is being asked going from
i've never given that advice
to i don't think a president would ever
feel it necessary to do that but the
question is if the president felt it
necessary to do that would it be a legal
thing to do so jim jordan doing the same
thing many republicans when they're
asked did joe biden win fair and square
they say joe biden is the president we
know joe biden's the president he was
sworn in it's another way to get around
having to actually substantively answer
these questions okay let's move on now
to another example of just
i don't know what you want to call it
just uh uh more more delusions
um many of you of course know fox news
host tucker carlson he has a highly
rated program on fox news he is seen as
sort of a thinking man's conservative by
many which i know is really difficult to
believe
he did an interview yesterday with a guy
named jason whitlock jason whitlock i
believe sort of originally yeah sports
columnist turned right-wing pundit jason
whitlock he's become a very popular
um
i i
i feel stupid calling him a cultural
critic but he's become a guy who weighs
in on cultural issues and the right
loves it and why they love it i don't
know i suspect maybe it's he has a fan
base from when he was in the sports
world eager to listen to him maybe the
fact that he's african-american makes
him useful to the conservative movement
as we've seen many times before for
whatever reason jason whitlock has quite
an audience he appeared on tucker
carlson's program with tucker carlson
and they were talking about the left
and jason whitlock says i think the left
is satanic
and tucker carlson agreed
this is
completely outrageous that this is
considered mainstream right-wing
political commentary at this time
let's take a look at it together finding
and destroying this country
what do you think i've always wondered
this like what is the actual support for
the ideas not you know do you like trump
or biden but for example do you think
men can get pregnant or do you think
some races are morally superior to other
races like the core idea is the
democratic party how many americans
actually believe that stuff would you
guess so first of all the questions are
crazy right
uh whether men can get pregnant those
may be the the terms that are being used
in some circles but that it's not really
an issue right i mean okay we can all
understand there might be a trans man
who was born biologically female and
thus
has the equipment with which they could
get pregnant but their their gender
identity could be male but we're not
really talking about whether biological
men can get pregnant the idea of the
democratic party
the idea that the democratic party has
as a core belief that some races are
superior to others of course that's
ridiculous so even the framing is
already crazy but it's just crazy upon
crazy
i don't think
five percent of america believes it
maybe ten percent i don't know but
tucker i'm going to say something that
difficult to unpack in this short amount
of time but it's what i truly believe i
think a lot of what the left supports is
satanic i'm just sorry it's it's in
direct objection
tucker says yeah now he'll agree more
but this is political analysis that the
beliefs are satanic to god and in direct
objection to the judeo-christian values
that were at the foundation of this
country and those christian values are
why we made so much
progress in terms of freedom and
humanity and the way we treat everybody
yes it was hard but our christian values
compelled us to sacrifice our lives for
the freedoms of other americans of
slaves and and through the civil rights
movement our christian values by the way
that's a civil rights movement that the
right was against but that's not
mentioned here compelled us to take
risks and fight for equality and the
equality of opportunity for everybody i
i just i see a lot of what's going on
here is i'm just sorry i'm a man of
faith i was raised in the church
this stuff is satanic that that's what's
at the foundation of a lot of this stuff
well i'm a pretty mild protestant
personally but i completely agree with
you
[Laughter]
even a mild protestant like tucker says
this is nothing other than the work of
satan especially the gender stuff when
you say you can change your own gender
by wishing it you're saying you're god
and that is satanic i i completely agree
this is completely and totally
delusional and there's a couple other
aspects to this one is
the satan stuff
it has q anon vibes it are are they
cow towing are they signaling
to the q anon people that
they are
specifically and noticeably on board
with the satan stuff there's like a
salem witch trials vibe to it
and lots of the stuff they talk about is
is very precisely crafted language like
change your own gender
versus you just address people with the
pronouns they prefer sounds much less
scary sounds much less strange sounds
much less supernatural when you say that
the problem is that people like tucker
to a degree jason whitlock
they're seen as thinkers by the right
which
right now the right is completely
missing any serious voices i mean who
like who is out there right now to be
taken seriously not that we agree with
them
andrew sullivan is a guy i have found
interesting for a long time
is he even really a right winger though
he's like a liberal conservative
catholic gay guy
he's disaffected with the right the
american right he's been disaffected
with it since george w bush does he even
really count doesn't mean i agree with
him on everything or even much
but he at least has had interesting
things to say but i'm not even sure that
he's really even a right winger he
certainly has nothing to do with these
people at this point
you know people like ben shapiro and dan
bongino
these are not real thinkers uh there's
really a dearth right now it's like
maybe neil ferguson and i'm not it's
always risky to do this because i'm not
saying i support them or endorse their
beliefs but i'm just saying there are
there are people who are doing more
serious thought coming to conclusions i
disagree with but this is just gutter
nonsense
at its core it's a very very sad state
of affairs
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p
this is a belated 16th anniversary
congratulation from the eggman let's
take a quick listen very nice message
hey dave um i had rural northern indiana
on my bingo board so i just won again
um hey listen man i missed you while you
were gone
so congratulations on six seventy
sixteen years it's been a long time you
know i've listened for like 14 of those
i've been leaving messages for like
almost 14. um i wanted to tell you that
jesse dollamore was great while you were
gone i'm now listening to his show as it
comes out oh yeah i always love baron
cuz he's also awesome
those guys were great i missed you i'm
glad you're back i'm glad you're healthy
um that's all shalom brother happy
anniversary it's been a hell of a ride
midweek politics one day with your
brother in the mom's basement shalom yes
now that's an exaggeration we used to
joke that we were broadcasting from my
mom's basement we never really were uh i
was like 30 at the time i had my own
place okay but i appreciate the uh
sentiment from the eggman we've got a
great bonus show for you today it turns
out the results of the arizona audit
are getting delayed
because a bunch of the people
involved in the audit
are sick with covid not a big surprise
also alex jones may be turning on donald
trump saying maybe he's a dumb ass we'll
talk about that and then lastly for a
very brief period solar power did
surpass coal power in australia and we
will talk about the significance of that
and much more all of those stories on
the bonus show
sign up at jointpacman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to
blinkist.com slash david pakman